this next story begins with a horrific
tragedy and that is a word horrific but
it's not about that our lead national
correspondent david becknow is here
because david i heard you say it's
really about strength it's about love
and most importantly it's about hope
bingo bingo good morning gail first a
warning part of the story we're about to
show you is hard to watch may not be
suitable for all children but this is a
story about what happened to 22 year old
jacqueline duran a college student and
an experienced dog sitter in north texas
she was mauled by two dogs
we have never before seen video of her
rescue which saved her life but not
before the dogs changed her face forever
i want you to know we spent the last two
months following this story her recovery
she's got a long road ahead
but she said to us i have a story to
tell and i want people to hear it and
she hopes you'll listen
jacqueline duran's face was nearly
erased two days before christmas and one
day before her 22nd birthday
it happened on a dog-sitting trip gone
horrifically wrong in the dallas texas
suburb of kappel i see her feet right
there first responder body camera video
shows the two dogs who attacked her
holding the police at bay
leaving jacqueline agonizing for help we
can't make entry because of the dogs the
dogs in the instant after she opened the
door we're not like the lovely dogs
jacqueline said she had met once before
sam can you hear me
are you the only one inside
is the big dog right next to you
lucy a german shepherd mix and bender a
boxer pit bull pinned her down and tore
off her nose ears lips and cheeks to the
bone so the dogs dragged you from the
front door
to the living room yes what do you
remember about where they were attacking
you
uh i like
my arm my face the most especially when
i felt the skin hanging from my face i
was just
i thought i was gonna die
from the time police arrived 37 minutes
passed before first responders felt safe
going in
a medic rescued jacqueline and ran out
with her she was rushed to a trauma
center in grave condition she had lost
30 percent of the blood in her body
it was a blessing really that she was
even found alive at all when the dogs
rushed her the door was left open and
that triggered a security alarm at the
home of justin and ashley bishop have
you had any problems with dogs
zero the bishops told police the dogs
came into their home from rescue
organizations i have three kids you know
one's three years old no no history
violence none
but the words crazy dogs on a sign about
a sleeping baby hanging on their front
door
is one indicator of negligence that is
according to a lawsuit filed by chip
brooker jacqueline's attorney the
warning on the front door to me i think
suggests that the bishops knew that both
of these dogs had acted aggressively
to people arriving at the front door
you're trying to build this case of
negligence what do you have to prove
that
what we have to prove is an examination
of the dogs that we did after this
attack which we believe shows that
the dogs were dangerous and had vicious
propensities
the bishops turned down a request by cbs
news for an interview but in a statement
they said they were heartbroken about
what happened the police videos show how
cautious officers were even when trying
to contain the dogs particularly bender
once at the hospital emergency surgery
lasted for seven hours
before jacqueline's parents john and
shirley duran heard from one of the
doctors she had to be resuscitated on
the trauma table multiple times
describe for me the moment you first saw
her after the attack
i was just glad to see her alive
her whole face was totally bandaged they
had her in a deduced coma
for over a week it must have been
somewhat deceiving because the bandages
really covered up the worst of it it did
it really did i just kept telling her
that she was a miracle and that
she was going to be restored
she will be
when we met jacqueline seven weeks after
she had been in the hospital
doctors had grafted skin from her
buttocks and her forehead to start the
process of rebuilding her face i
feel like
i didn't ask her this so
i think that
it's time to
show who i am now and i can't be scared
of it what are you hoping to get across
with this interview i want for dog
owners to know
their animals
and
be able to communicate with their
sitters how they are these are the same
dogs who you had met a week earlier that
you said were lovely yeah you know
lovely one week and killers the next how
do you square the two honestly i'm
speechless they don't change their
attitude from the time that i eat them
to the time that i go there for the
first time jacqueline was released from
the hospital after 60 days leaving there
was a brave and spirited 22 year old
woman deserving of the applause that she
got from the doctors and nurses
when she got home first responders gave
her a champions welcome i really
appreciate it
[Applause]
her dogs were even waiting and so was
her boyfriend
jacqueline doesn't want to be seen as a
victim
but rather an example and that may be
why she didn't hide the scars that
showed the more than 800 bites on her
body
so when i first interviewed you you
could open your mouth about five
millimeters yes now you're up to 21
millimeters yes we've had the benefit of
watching you heal over the course of a
month and it is notably different better
are you seeing that yourself yeah i have
seen and
what does that do just for your own
spirits
i think it it really
lucy compared to where i was yeah
because i just felt so
helpless in the hospital and being at
home i knew i was gonna heal more here
than i could at the hospital therapy is
a full-time job now her mouth is
stretched one millimeter at a time so
that she can eat more
countless surgeries are to come when you
hear one to three more years of
surgeries is that daunting for you
it's
not fun to think about but i also think
out how
amazing the doctors are
and so
i'm
putting it in their hands to help me
come on
you should know that there's a lot of
hope in jacqueline and her family
in fact in looking to the future guess
what there is a place in her heart still
to love dogs she'd been dog sitting for
seven years and still dreams of working
with animals the last we spoke you
mentioned
maybe
something involving animal welfare
i was thinking dog training because
that's dog training yes that's my dream
but
i'm not sure where life is gonna take me
yet she has her senses now
she can walk she can talk she can smell
she can hear and she can see
she's gonna be fine
i think hi
in addition to the love from her family
there is 24 year old nathan who she has
dated for three years
he just recovered from cancer and when
he was going through treatment
jacqueline often drove him and stayed
with him now
i'm so grateful that i get the
opportunity to
show the same level of love and care
that she showed me during that time i'm
glad that i get the chance to
i'm glad that i get to be there for her
jacqueline told us she'd like to hear
from the bishops she has not she said
david i would like an apology she says i
haven't even been paid in full for the
service that i went there for
i should tell you that the bishops told
us in their statement that they would
never put anyone in harm's way and a
texas judge ordered that both of the
dogs be euthanized